[Music]
nathan i got to tell you when i saw your
video
my first reaction was this is a damn
mood it just like made me so happy
and i feel like during a time where
there's just so much heaviness like in
the news and around the world
uh it was nice to see you just bopping
on your skateboard drinking the
cranberry juice to fleetwood mac i mean
how does it feel like for you to uh put
a smile on so many people's faces like
that
it's insane you know i mean and i know i
know my videos bring smiles and
everything and this one just surpassed
you know craziness it's just it's insane
like i said it's i feel blessed that so
many people can
get so much joy out of this video that i
did you know what i mean
it's so amazing and you got skills man i
don't know many people who can
skateboard and
chug some juice while they're doing it
uh is this like a normal thing
is this is this like a typical afternoon
now for you
basically you don't get i don't know not
a typical night you know but yeah
that's what i do you know i mean i love
skateboarding longboarding i love penny
boarding i do all three you know
it's they all have their own different
styles you know and
it's just a vibe in itself you know just
going out and
skating or longboarding and just
listening to music and
like i said this one was just awesome
because i was able to do the
all three like you said you know and i
seen the comments people were saying
that multitasking like no other you know
and
it's just it just felt natural you know
what i mean it's just yeah yeah
i gotta know what was your family's
reaction once this went
super viral it's been insane you know
like i said
i didn't really get get or take notice
to it until my mom
and my auntie started sending me it in
messenger and everything you know and
i'm like
you know why are they sending it to me
now you know i was like other people
usually send it to me and yeah
it's viral and stuff but when my mom and
then my aunties and everybody started
sending it to me that's when i realized
okay maybe this is actually bigger than
i think it is
oh my god it still is oh wait so are you
a big fleetwood mac
fan yeah no doubt you know what i mean
growing up my mom that's all she
listened to you know
my uncles my aunties everybody and then
like to now you know just to keep
listening to him my my daughter
you know she comes from montana with her
mom and everything and she was listening
to oldies as well you know and just
blast and play with always and
like i said it's always around you know
oh for sure so then what was your first
reaction when you saw
mick doing what you were doing
it was insane because i was like whoa
mick fleetwood has a tick tock account
you know
and then i went inside his videos to go
check it out and i was like no he made a
tick tock account
just to do this video and then that was
like insane and like yeah just
you know what i mean one of your heroes
like totally yeah no doubt
paying tribute to you isn't that so
crazy he put my name in the comments and
everything you know what i mean i
actually even got a letter from him and
everything it's just insane
yeah you know you've heard from mick
have you heard from stevie nicks or any
of the other members yet
no as far as them tweeting it on twitter
like i said that that was blessing in
itself you know i think that helped out
a lot you know
i'm glad they love the video it's just
awesome
i know you also got some love from ocean
spray
do you recognize the juice
promotion spray to you thanks for
keeping it positive
that wasn't paid endorsement right
that's just your favorite juice
yeah dude straight up like i said
there's i would
just cruising with my jesus you know
what i mean it was insane and then for
them to go
out and get me a truck you know what i
mean like and then to have it presented
to me
by my daughter you know it was just it
was insane man they went they went all
out and like i said i
it's just oh man i don't know it's crazy
that it's new and everything you know
it's it's just a blessing man i get to
drive from here to montana without
without worrying about it
dying out or anything you know and it
was a trooper you know what i mean that
that that dodging whatever but yeah it's
awesome
so are you spending more time in the
truck now than you are the longboard or
is it
no it's funny the other day i was like
my
my uh what is it my cousin came to see
me yesterday
and then she's like hey what are you
doing because my daughter facetimed me
here
and i was at my girlfriend's house and
she was like what are you doing like
nothing she's like why did you take your
truck
i was like oh i decided long board over
here you know
and the truck goes outside in front and
she's like i thought you were here and i
was like no i just decided longboard you
know
she's like man you're crazy if it ain't
broke don't fix it right
amen you know what i mean okay so
mick fleetwood did the video he was
skateboarding
what was your reaction to seeing a bunch
of other people kind of uh do the meme
as well including i think i saw
chimpanzee
also vibing out yeah i seen that one
recently my cousin in oregon sent that
to me
yeah you know what i mean it's just
insane and
just seeing all of them you know i mean
they gave me the numbers i can't even
remember their
oh man 130 something thousand on tick
tock people that actually do edit it or
something like that
and then 500 million people who actually
did that did it or something i don't
like i said numbers are crazy
yeah and it's insane did you ever
imagine that you'd be a tick tock star
no you know what i mean just i was
always just dancing and doing what i do
you know what i mean like i said i get
comments from people you know saying it
brought them joy to see my video you
know oh this song reminded me of the
past all this song reminded me a loved
one this song reminded me of
you know whatever you know it was just
always i was always just getting joy of
people's joy you know just
seeing that you know some people say oh
i was crying for three days straight i
seen your video it made me laugh
you know i'm like wow you know that's
just it's just amazing you know
you can get that through a nap you know
and it's just amazing that i can reach
people that way
now there were talks that you're going
to work with travis scott
on an upcoming project what can you tell
us did he reach out to you
no i have no clue like i said that in an
interview i said that would be
honestly cool if somebody like travis
scott could reach out to me or something
you know and
get me on something you know because
like i said i'm trying to
i'm trying to get something you know i'm
trying to do work or something i can you
know promotions or something
instead of taking or getting donations
you know i'd rather do something
like i said i'm a worker that's what
i've always been i've worked since
since i was 14 not constantly you know
but
ever since i dropped out of school in
10th grade that's all i've done is work
you know so
i'm a worker i want to work and i just
want to
yeah just be out there obviously your
story is so fascinating and like i'd
even realize that you know you dropped
out of high school
what message you have for people out
there who i don't know maybe struggling
with themselves right now
and you you know with your newfound
internet fame at this moment in your
life what message you have for them
if you guys are struggling like i said
go out and do something that makes you
happy
is if it's simple as dancing if it's
simple as taking a walk
you know down the street you know or
skating you know just anything that
makes you happy
that you know because everybody knows in
themselves what makes them happy what
can make them smile
so go out and do that and then just just
you know just forget about what people
are thinking
people are saying if they're if they're
thinking about you or saying anything
about you
while you're doing what you're doing
because be you you know what i mean just
be you
hey listen it's all about the hustle i'm
just
happy it got you this far you know oh
yeah you're gonna ride the train but you
got me wanted to ride on a long board
okay i was lit
i was bumping fleetwood map while i was
getting ready today and that was because
of you so
cheers
you